oh you know you are you were in it Merry
Christmas Happy Hanukkah happy Kwanzaa
and Happy Holidays period this year to
celebrate on December 18th we are
hosting a live BuzzFeed holiday special
featuring some of your favorite BuzzFeed
personalities coming together to
celebrate the holidays and to thank them
for participating I've decided to bake
them a festive fruit cake having never
even tried a fruit cake I bring in
Matthew Francis a tasty producer to help
guide me on this endeavor there's a fun
shaped yeah a bundt pan that's why it's
called a bundt pan it's a fun it's a fun
pan specifically using a very pared down
recipe with vague instructions I begin
work on a fruit cake that hopefully
won't kill my colleagues it softened
butter and sugar in a large bowl and
cream together with mixer until well
beaten our fluffy we don't have a mixer
so we're gonna use an arm hung up with
the sugar and yet Jack I'm softening the
butter okay all right so paper towels
keep rolling you can't grab it mix it up
there if you want one no no I'm up we're
gonna doing this the hard way
oh okay great all right okay all right
I'm back all right
softened butter and sugar a large bowl
not sure how much sugar we'll just tuck
in a bunch of sugar okay for this part
definitely the wist shuffle will sugar a
little more well I say great things
it's butter and sugar you know I missed
the day's ride is visit a porn company
good while I actually enjoyed cooking it
starts being clear that baking on the
other hand is definitely not one of my
strong suits
luckily noticing my struggles matthew
tries to help me as best he can
[Music]
mix the flour separately with the spices
and sugar and stuff in the flour yeah
[Music]
I mixed in the batter it's not beyond
the world okay cool I'm guessing even if
you have an opening on tasty I'm
probably not gonna well hmm yeah you're
good at what you do all right
good two three then we do one more
method
don't worry i'ma tell people I made this
with Matthew Johnson great well paste
Jack it's rude oh do you edit cocoa
powder 2 or 3 tablespoons of thing
now it says fold in pecans walnuts
rehydrated fruit with its liquid this is
a real treat you know what that's good
oh go wild it Cheers yeah talk about
that it's like a chocolate cake batter
cake batter with fruit than that yeah
there's a saying when you work in
restaurants area clean station clean
mind so keep that in mind for next time
oh there's my next time where we can
work together again sure the process
getting here was a little bit and just
saying but we're here sometimes it's not
about the destination it's about the
journey and I think they're finally
gonna have enough wow look at that
Wow this is not bad let that will work
as fruitcake yeah happy holidays happy
holidays Cheers just a cake
it tastes like fruitcake is it actually
isn't that bad how was it okay for
fruitcake
it tastes correct it's just fruitcake is
this like meth you wanna take when they
go for their own good
sure yeah at least I'm on your desk okay
great with this delicious treat complete
I head around the office to hand out
samples as an early Christmas gift to my
colleagues you don't want any Jason it's
a holiday fruitcake this is candy green
cherry delight I'm the only person I
know who likes fruitcake
so you're gonna be the ultimate judge of
this and I want you to be honest with me
hey what are you doing this is a bush of
brandy you gotta have a little brush you
gotta have a little brush what do you
think
what a treat that was wasn't it
[Music]
Thank You choice thank you yeah I really
worked hard on it all day it's not as
bad as I thought I'd be it's not as bad
as a hood there's not that good
Wow I can taste the load it tastes like
something really Drive good I don't hate
it the more I know the more I'm like
okay all right baby
no I don't want more well you are more
than welcome out somewhere you have a
nice big slice December 18th
3:00 p.m. Pacific time BuzzFeed live
holiday special tune in takes a long
time shooters
no bite